física barreras es la directora del
programa de español de la ucam o del
programa en español de la ucam que en
pocos días más en muy pocas horas más va
a llevar a cabo una videoconferencia
sobre la influencia de las lenguas
indígenas en el español y las nuevas
formas de hacer investigación de la mano
de los pueblos indígenas puede por favor
y jessica darnos una mirada más amplia
de qué se trata de esta propuesta claro
que sí buenas tardes y gracias por esta
oportunidad para hablar un poquito más
de de este esfuerzo que yo diría surge
de inquietudes lingüísticas de mi parte
para dar a conocer más esta realidad de
todas estas lenguas autóctonas que
muchas veces son dejadas de lado no muy
conocidas entonces
un año más o menos conocimos los
trabajos de la profesora marlene a wood
y con ella hicimos una breve conferencia
porque ya tiene un proyecto inmenso que
se llama proyecto oralidad modernidad y
es un proyecto que tiene diferentes
diferentes aspectos una es la
revitalización del quechua en las zonas
de ecuador otro es volver a conectar
estas generaciones no de abuelos padres
e hijos muchas veces estos espacios
comunes culturales se han perdido sea
por la modernidad sea por la falta de
tiempo o sea por lo remoto de las zonas
entonces el trabajo de la profesora [ __ ]
ha sido fundamental para
dar a conocer para ayudar a estas
comunidades y creo que el aspecto más
bonito es para valorizar estas personas
porque siempre teníamos en la mente la
idea de que son investigadores que
vienen a estas comunidades para
investigarlos pero creo que una de las
cosas más importantes es que podemos
también aprender de ellos y ellos mismos
tienen todo la formación toda la
sabiduría también para inspirar a otros
investigadores entonces convencida de
que vale la pena apoyar estos esfuerzos
estamos muy contentos de poder tener la
conferencia de la doctora marlene a
woods
mañana jueves jessica y tratándose de la
universidad de quebec en montreal la
primera pregunta que surge es por qué
debería interesarle a los estudiantes al
curso o agua o al agua a la universidad
en sí misma y a quienes puedan
participar de este encuentro una
conferencia que se refiere a la
situación de lenguas indígenas en un
lugar tan distante como el ecuador y
bueno es una excelente pregunta yo creo
que el interés sale de todo el futuro de
las lenguas y de toda la vitalidad de
las lenguas en general a veces por
motivos de popularidad se decide enseñar
el español los he decidido enseñar otro
otro idioma pero yo creo que es es como
lingüista y como mi especialidad
sociolingüista cuando estaba en los
estudios estaba en un proyecto que
trataba sobre algunas lenguas aborígenes
de quebec
y yo entendía el peligro de extinción si
se dejaba que el francés invadiera estas
comunidades y finalmente desaparece con
la lengua la cultura entonces bueno
hicimos camino más adelante en entré en
mi función de metro de dragón en español
y después de directora y yo dije que
bueno es poder hablar del español pero
también el español que cohabita con
otras con otras lenguas y que no tenemos
que tener miedo sino que darle espacio
hay suficiente espacio para para estas
interacciones para hablantes de
diferentes idiomas no solo en el ecuador
porque no soy ecuatoriana tampoco pero
es una realidad común a muchísimos
países
casi internacionalmente y yo creo que
también pensando en el año 2019 que es
cuando las naciones unidas celebra esta
este año internacional de las lenguas
autóctonas pues dije hay que hacer algo
y esa fue un poco la misión de la
escuela de lenguas y del del
departamento de español específicamente
el ucam
en los últimos tiempos ha empezado a
circular un poco más la expresión o el
término revitalización de qué hablamos
cuando hablamos de revitalizar una
lengua es es muy interesante porque
revitalizar una lengua no solamente es
una lengua que estaba por ejemplo
difunta sino que se vuelve a hacer
popular pero que se vuelve a valorizar y
yo creo que ese es el
el dato más importante la característica
más importante que tenemos todos porque
yo siento como una responsabilidad
cultural ética de que las próximas
generaciones tengan esta
tengan esta posibilidad en sus propios
países y hay muchos esfuerzos de los que
estamos en las universidades pero
también en diferentes comunidades de
darles espacio de integrarlos y de
nosotros también hacer puentes no
y tener un contacto más activo entonces
en ese sentido yo creo que es este
proceso de revitalización es saber
cuáles son los medios para que estas
lenguas perduren cómo se les puede
ayudar también en estas comunidades
que puedan tener programas de sus
idiomas
y qué
y que tengan es que dejen este legado
para las próximas generaciones no nos
vamos a escapar del tema de la
conferencia pero ustedes nombraba hace
unos instantes las lenguas indígenas de
la provincia de québec a las hay en
quebec y las hay en las otras provincias
canadienses también trazando un paralelo
con este interés de la profesora wood en
las lenguas del ecuador cree que los
esfuerzos aquí en quebec y en canadá en
general para preservar las lenguas
indígenas o para revitalizar las en todo
caso son suficientes yo pienso que hay
todavía mucho por hacer en la época en
que yo estaba en este proyecto con la
lengua de montañez aquí en quebec
estaban tratando de hacer como un
diccionario no es solamente con un
diccionario no es suficiente porque yo
creo que eso es una parte muy somera de
la investigación
tratar como esta comunidad como
ayudarles para que entre ellos mismos
podamos formar a profesores y que sigan
en esta bella labor es el caso de una
colega y es una profesora que también
trabaja con nosotros jiménez de raza que
ha hecho también este que participa
activamente en este proceso de
revitalización finalmente de la lengua y
de la comunidad
hemos hablado recientemente con ella le
hemos tenido como invitada también aquí
en nuestro espacio y quienes hemos
estudiado en su caso lingüista lingüista
de perdón lingüística o en el caso mío o
de otras personas comunicación o
estudios que tienen que ver con la
lengua sabemos que esta es una
herramienta central
en la relación de las personas con el
mundo que lo rodean se dice que cuando
una lengua desaparece desaparece una
forma de ver el mundo una forma de
definir al mundo y una forma de
relacionarse con ese mundo que nos rodea
se habla también mucho de las lenguas
que están en peligro de desaparición
puede ser el estado de esas lenguas aquí
en canadá están realmente en peligro de
desaparición hay herramientas
suficientes como para que esa
desaparición no se produzca pues yo creo
que la situación aquí es diferente tal
vez porque estamos más cerca de la
provincia de québec y porque tenemos
apoyo de los gobiernos locales no
entonces depende si eso entra entre las
prioridades de un gobierno y de entender
y de tener esa mentalidad abierta en
nuestros países es un poquito más
difícil porque muchas veces se dice pero
es que no hay no hay fondos disponibles
para estos programas pero yo pienso que
es súper importante
no sólo el aspecto monetario sino el
esfuerzo y creer en el proyecto entonces
para volver un poco al caso del quechua
o del quechua como dicen en ecuador
hay un profesor también en la
universidad de montreal que en paralelo
trabaja con la profesora wood
y que se especializa en ese terreno es
un terreno que no debería ser tan
extranjero para nosotros debería ser
algo del cual estamos orgullosos debería
hacer algo de que podamos hablar a
nuestros hijos
a los colegas quién sabe en un futuro
próximo podamos ofrecer clases en la
misma escuela de idiomas sobre estas
lenguas porque yo no veo ninguna
rivalidad yo veo más tengo un enfoque
como más inclusivo y tienen ellos tanto
derecho de existir como las que
conocemos física para quienes no la
conocen aún abrimos un poco por favor de
la escuela de lenguas de la ucam y
específicamente del programa en español
pues muy bien la escuela de lenguas
como proyecto dentro del camp hace ya
varios años como unos 20 años más o
menos y se daban al principio lenguas
como el inglés obviamente francés para
extranjeros español y al principio el
español era visto como la idioma para
viajar para las personas quebequenses
que querían conocer otras otras
realidades y para los hombres de
negocios
yo tenía fortuna de estar desde los
primeros años en la escuela de lenguas
en el programa de español justamente y
he visto una evolución muy positiva en
cuanto al español porque ya pasa a ser
de una de una lengua para el turismo o
para los negocios a una lengua que
realmente busca
busca dar la oportunidad para que las
personas se impliquen en el extranjero
para que las personas se impliquen en la
misma comunidad que en montreal que
tenemos tantos hispanohablantes para que
para que estas esta presencia en el
medio en los diarios en la radio en la
televisión sea parte de un cotidiano
entonces yo diría que yo creo en el
multilingüismo
y no en el monolingüismo entonces el
programa de español ha ido evolucionando
y tenemos cursos justamente por ejemplo
cursos de lengua general en los cursos
en los niveles más bajos y más adelante
entonces tenemos cursos como
comunicación oral y turismo tenemos
españa y américa latina es un curso que
estoy dando en este momento por ejemplo
y que me encanta porque la gente piensa
que un curso de historia son fechas son
eventos pero tiene mucha relación con lo
que pasa hoy
entonces si analizamos algún evento pues
remontar a las circunstancias entender
mejor la problemática
y me gusta esos espacios de reflexión
entonces yo creo que la visión del
programa de español del campo
es muy pragmático es
un espacio para discutir y casi con el
pretexto de una temática ir aprendiendo
el idioma podemos entonces invitar a los
interesados y decirles que la escuela de
lenguas de local bien especial el
programa en español que es el sitio al
que pueden recurrir se les interesa
aprender la lengua y perfeccionarla ya
sea usualmente para viajar sino para
buscar una inserción laboral también e
incluso para comprender para entender y
para saber un poco más de españa y de
américa latina no solamente de su lengua
exactamente y quisiera mencionar un
proyecto también que está relacionado
con el programa de español y del cual
estoy muy orgullosa que es la escuela de
verano en bogotá porque cuando partió
este proyecto hace tres años la gente me
decía pero ir a colombia estás loca la
inseguridad todo el mundo prefiere otros
destinos un poco más cercanos no sé
españa tal vez méxico
y yo dije no tratemos y apostemos a
américa latina y bueno toco
me tocó pues hacer muchas citas tratar
de convencer a las personas y fue un
éxito fue un éxito tremendo el primer
año tuvimos
más o menos unas 20 personas
quebequenses que iban a bogotá para esta
inversión el año después se agregaron 10
más 30 el año antes de la pandemia
teníamos 39 personas entonces yo creo
que estaba muy orgullosa de de crear
este espacio de colaboración de poder
brindar otra cara de américa latina' a
los estudiantes quebequenses de aquí y
decir que si es posible tomar toma un
poco de tiempo tomar
tal vez
romper los estereotipos que es un poco
también una parte de la conferencia de
la profesora a put que está rompiendo el
estereotipo que tenemos de la imagen de
que alguien vaya estudio en la comunidad
y la comunidad es pasiva y se queda
tranquila no la comunidad es muy activa
y puede desarrollar
estas maneras de conocerse mejor y de
enseñar a otras comunidades por último
significa estamos grabando esta
entrevista el día miércoles 10 de marzo
por la tarde sabemos que la conferencia
es el jueves 11 de marzo a las 6 hora de
montreal pero quienes se interesen en
este evento como pueden participar
una corrección es a las nueve y treinta
de la mañana por la mañana jueves de 9
30 a las 12 si van a la página facebook
del programa de español de la escuela de
lenguas del icam lo pueden lo pueden ver
es una conferencia abierta a todos todas
las instrucciones están allí y es para
otra otra
otro aspecto que me gusta de la
profesora marlene era que ella quería
ver las caras de las personas porque a
veces cuando se hace un buen binario
pues no se no se ve a nadie pero en esta
en este aspecto inclusivo pues vamos a
tener personas de ecuador- que se van a
conectar vamos a tener el embajador de
ecuador que va a estar allí para darle
bienvenida a la investigadora y a la
comunidad en general otros profesores
otras universidades entonces invitamos a
todos a que nos acompañen va a ser una
mañana
muy bien invertida si yo sé que todos
estamos ocupados y que a lo mejor a
veces es difícil y también vamos a tener
la grabación de la conferencia también
disponible
porque va a ser facebook en vivo pero va
a quedar allí en el facebook de la
escuela de lenguas si hay personas que
les gustaría volverla a ver y que no
pueden por el horario de la conferencia
wing jessica pateras directora del
programa en español de la escuela de
lenguas de la ucam ma muchas gracias por
esta entrevista con radio que nos da
internacional
muchas gracias por limitarlo